grow up in Deon now for about a year and
a half I'm in my late 30s she's in her
mid-30s um you know it's time to just
kind of keep going through those motions
of of relationships moving on and uh
beautiful girl she you know checks all
the boxes cooks dinner you know doesn't
fight against much of what I ask for but
more recently two things have kind of
come up that are a little bit more
irritating one is um the lack of you
know she tends to go a longer period of
time without shaving her legs and um is
a little gassy openly while we're at
home together and I'm hoping that you
know obviously she's not listening or
anything close to that um you know i' so
she's a hairy
farter yeah and honestly she's a
beautiful blonde hair green eyes great
physique a beautiful girl so it's not
something that you know she's not
atrocious in any way yeah um
and I've just you know more recently
I've said look you know these are things
that I expect you to kind of maintain a
feminist personality in place and I'm
going to maintain my masculine side yeah
and uh for these two particular things
I've found them to be you know not not
appealing uh it's been going on now for
like four or five months where I am
consistently saying hey come on you know
I don't find that attractive cut it out
yeah um am I asking for something that
is you know unreasonable no um no I
don't think so at all look man I've I've
met few like very very few women that
that let them rip in front of you I mean
they you know if they got to let one rip
they're usually pretty quiet about it
really discreet like they don't even
notice it they don't they don't want to
play like you know like musical farts or
anything like that um you know do humans
fart yes uh but for women to do it it's
not very feminine um it's it's not a
turn on I completely agree with what
you're saying did she do it when you
first met her no not at all and
it's how many weeks months in did she
start doing that um we've been dating
for about a year and a half now and I
would tell you over the last five to six
months it's become more of a you know
she does it and kind of laughs right
it's not smelly it's not after you know
it's her own personal digestive issues
whatever yeah um you know it's not
happening in public it's just at the
confines of our home laying on the couch
and yeah you know and um yeah like yeah
somebody said here in the chat it's
disrespectful right because it's a turn
off to you so the way that I would
handle that is like
look you need to keep doing what got you
in the door okay like I I chose you and
I'm still continuing to choose you but
this is irritating so knock it off I'm
not going to tolerate this you need to
stop doing this if you've got gas issues
or if you got some indigestion you got
something that's Crea in the gas then
figure it out you know go to a doctor
figure out what it is uh you probably
got some inflammatory responses to
certain types of food that you're taking
um you know eating there there's a um
there's a MRT test it's a called MRT
leap you know if you want to jot this
down and it's A1
thousand it's A1 thousand blood test and
what they'll do is they'll test your
blood up against different foods and
they'll tell you what kind of foods
cause inflam
against the blood it's a histamine test
um I've done it I'm on a special diet
because of it and I'll tell you one of
the things that happened you know right
away when I went on the dieters I
stopped farting I fart like almost never
now right when guys fart it's not a big
deal it's kind of expected you know for
guys to like let them rip and have a
laugh but it's not do that you know
fortunately I don't have that problem
right I mean like some people have that
problem like you know where they just
get gas from certain foods like you can
fix it right I mean clearly she knew
that it was unattractive when she met
you and and she was on her best behavior
and then when she sat you down and said
Greg I dig your Vibe I don't want to
share you I want to claim you where do
we stand and you know you're looking at
her going yep sounds good and then she
just starts letting them rip you know
when she gets comfortable well what she
going to do if you guys have kids
together like what she going to do if
you guys live together full-time what
you g to do if you guys decide to do
something like get married right if you
know she's letting her go in that
letting herself go in that sense same
thing with the leg hair right like you
know I mean if you don't keep yourself
looking tidy and nice you're not going
to be attractive right like if you don't
keep your haircut or your beard tight
like if I grew one of these shitty ass
like homeless beards and just look like
nasty I would be a turnoff to my gal
right but I don't I keep it tight I go
in every week the guy cleans it up for
me I'm on a schedule um you know like I
maintain a certain standard because it's
incumbent upon me as a man to maintain
certain standards of you know
masculinity and strength and all these
other things that I always talk about so
I would just go back to look you know
you need to keep doing what got you in
the door if you stop doing what got you
in the door then that's going to be a
problem and this doesn't have legs like
this is gonna end right so right and and
her position on that is because we're at
that point now where I've you know
brought it up and it's become a more
serious topic where there's you know
yeah half a bag of stuff packed ready to
call it quits in both directions over
what you know over these non you know
these non these smaller issues in the
grand scheme of relationships and um
you know she her position is you should
love me for who I am if the tide was
turned she would not love you if if you
went broke Greg you got loads of real
estate you're a successful guy you got
things going on in your life like you've
called in before yeah I know the name
right like you're not a bum if you lost
everything okay she would not love you
for who you are she would start looking
elsewhere so that whole you know love me
for for who I am [__] no women are
Beauty objects are supposed to be
feminine right they were told from you
know the gecko sugar and spice and all
things nice so start behaving and acting
in accordance with what women are if you
can't do that if you can't behave in a
feminine way and you you know you want
to let them rip and you're going to be
you know growing leg hair and you know
getting lazy and [__] I'm just going to
replace you it's as simple as
that 104 that was uh what I was wasn't
expecting any different of raise your
standards you know just like the last
guy it's it's raise your standards or
you know in your case all you're doing
is you already had standards and she
already had standards but she got lazy
and relaxed and grew leg hair and
started farting like what's next she's
going to get
fat that would be a I'm gonna I'm gonna
drop off this call before I say anything
else to you know get myself in a trouble
because I've turned on some of her
friends her guy friends or you know to
watching the show so yeah it's my Cee to
go it's it's it's up to you guys to set
these boundaries and to maintain them
right women will get lazy if you let
them sounds cool Greg thank you sir all
right brother look guys you know if
you're dealing with a chick you're
dating she's doing all the right things
she's coming over she's cooking you
meals she's making your bed in the
morning you know she's cleaning up after
herself um women will start to get lazy
over time uh it's just part of the
nature of relationship as they sort of
develop you get comfortable getting
comfortable in the sense of the regard
where you're letting like if you're and
you're letting farts rip if you're
letting like your leg hair grow and
you're not keeping yourself tidy and
feminine um you know that's going to
lead to getting fat it's going to get
you know it's going to lead to other
things like you know you've got to have
these conversations you know if she
starts with let's say you know something
simple like you know she comes over she
makes her bed in the morning before she
leaves kisses you goodbye I'll see you
whenever sort of thing and she starts to
get lazy and stop making the bed it's up
to you as a guy to enforce that boundary
that you know that was set that that
standard that had existed because women
have to keep doing what they did to get
themselves in the door if they stop
doing what got them in the door and got
the commitment then they don't get to
keep the commitment it's as simple as
that so you need to figure out a way to
deliver that message it doesn't have to
be tur it doesn't have to be mean or
unkind but kind men still know how to
enforce boundaries I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out